do you remember who these people are and
do you remember why they are so
important do you really remember
WikiLeaks and what the leaks meant you
know those thousands of classified
records showing government cover-ups
lies details of torture indiscriminate
killings in secret drone campaigns and
what if I told you the WikiLeaks cables
might have warned us about the rise of
the Islamic state group their lightning
sweep of Iraq and Syria this year caught
all of us off guard but why they've been
planning this for years and the proof
has been available to the public since
2010 WikiLeaks has published almost
3,000 documents that mentioned the
Islamic State of Iraq which morphed over
time and absorbed others into the
Islamic state group that we know today
in fact never mind us the public the US
government might have been better placed
to face the threat of the group and the
ongoing disaster in Iraq and Syria if it
chose to read its own classified
documents instead of spending years
trying to silence the messengers so who
really remembers WikiLeaks
[Music]
this person over here do you recognize
this person no really no how about this
person no have you ever heard of
WikiLeaks Ricki Lake what does it means
doesn't ring a bell
what is WikiLeaks leaking information to
the government that's been obscured from
the general public is it a good thing
yeah can I ask you who this guy is do
you know this man is is it an old story
or is it ongoing I would say that it's
an old story you know him being out of
the limelight has taken on a lot of
attention away from the story and what
if I told you you could actually still
go into those cables read all of them
you know that they very much inform you
about what's actually going on right now
WikiLeaks continues to leak classified
documents to the world many trace the
evolution of the Islamic state group to
2006 back when they were still known as
ISI here are just a few examples 2010
document illustrates the growth of ISI
after its leader dies the death of a
single competent leader is not
necessarily a permanent and devastating
blow to an organization like AI acai the
ISI survived the 2006 death of
al-zarqawi and actually increased its
operational tempo in 2007 and the
Islamist groups that Bashar al-assad
warns are a threat to the world he's
actually had a long-established
relationship with them former Syrian
prisoners were encouraged by their
government to join the insurgency in
Iraq according to a cable from 2010 acid
allowed prisoners to train in Syria for
combat operations in Iraq and while
President Obama praised Iraq so called
unity government's prime minister leads
Iraq's most inclusive government yet the
cables showed that US officials were
aware and deeply concerned of former
Iraqi Prime Minister Nouri al-maliki's
discrimination against Sunni Muslims in
2007 when US officials warned him of
sectarian Shia officials operating
within the Iraqi military al-maliki
responded with it's impossible now we
have barely scratched the surface there
are thousands of cables out there why
don't you take a look for yourself
what'd you find
want more download the aj+ mobile app
and join the conversation
available in your app store now